هل ينتمي الأناناس للبيتزا ، حسنًا ،
توقف السويد عن تناول الأناناس
وترفع الموز على البيتزا بالكاري والبيتزا
والبيتزا
بجدية في السويد ، لذا دعونا ننسى
الأناناس لأنهم هنا في السويد
لديهم طريقة مختلفة تمامًا
للبيتزا هنا إنها بيتزا تتصدر مجانًا
للجميع  لقد كان طبيبي يطبخ البيتزا منذ
25 عامًا وسيخبرك أن كل شيء
يسير
مثل الموز والموز ، إنه المتعصب حتى الآن
شاكر سيهز ، لذا فإن هذا
اليوم المميز الذي منعه ظهرًا في
كاري بونهام آنا ، فماذا تأكل الحلويات
في الصيف ، يكون سعر شيبا زهيدًا بالكامل
على Hatton Mamma Mia
إذا كان مهرجان Malaga يقدم طعامًا فرنًا من
وعاء Malaga Rose وماء فاسد
أو بيبروني ،
يمكن لشاهدين كانوا نعسانًا جدًا معرفة ما إذا كانوا
مخطئين ، أعني من لا يحب الكباب  إذاً
محيط من مطعم لا باستا بيتزا ، ما هو موجود في
عربة القائمة الخاصة بك براد كوربن على الكاري
أو الروبيان صاحب الشركة ،
أوه قل ليس كذلك السويد ، أوه هناك المزيد
من بيتزا الكاري وهي الدجاج
والموز بالكاري والصينية  ple أو
الموز المفضل لدي من Tropicana ham و Rene's
mm-hmm wipe ، هذه ليست مجرد وجبة خفيفة في وقت متأخر من الليل ، هل
هي Nirvana Toscana شحذ
جسدها الإيطالي مع أفضل
مرضى Eduardo على شريك por que
trata دون Vila
wanton pizza order M de  القديس ميران
الآن للسؤال الحقيقي لماذا
أعادت السويد اختراع
منظار الأذن أجرافادا بلاندينا لنظام غذائي مثالي بالفعل ،
لذا قاموا بصنع صينية صغيرة يقول
بيتزا الكباب والأعلاف الأحادية النيئة ، يمكنك
تأخير بيتزا غابانا إلى حد
ما ، ما هي بالتأكيد بذكاء و  الآن
الجزء الأكثر أهمية الذي مذاقه
جيد حقًا
[موسيقى]